un encuentro que puso las cartas sobre
la mesa el alto representante para
asuntos exteriores de la Unión Europea
giuseppey fue recibido en Cuba por el
presidente Miguel Díaz canel pese a las
diferencias existentes de ascanel
reconoció la importancia de los lazos
históricos y culturales entre el bloque
unitario y Cuba para favorecer el
diálogo yo creo que hay tanto en el
ámbito político diplomático como en el
ámbito de la cooperación
hay un camino que se ha ido ordenando y
que va dando resultados y creo que las
potencialidades en el futuro Son son
amplios
también opinó sobre dos temas clave en
la relación de la isla con Estados
Unidos Empezando por el embargo tengo
que esforzarme para mantener la unidad
de todos en el voto las Naciones Unidas
en contra del bloqueo tengo que
esforzarme para que todos entiendan que
incluir a Cuba en la lista de los países
que apoyan el terrorismo de una
barbaridad la reunión se dio en el
contexto la realización del Consejo
conjunto Cuba Unión Europea un espacio
que intenta facilitar el acercamiento de
Bruselas con América Latina en las
discusiones y tocó el sensible tema de
los Derechos Humanos los derechos de las
personas derechos humanos lo que
llamamos libertades políticas que
incluyen los derechos a las
manifestaciones pacíficas la elección de
los gobiernos de forma libre y
democrática también se conversó sobre la
guerra en Ucrania Cuba mantuvo su
posición de no estar de acuerdo con la
invasión Aunque dirige la culpa a
Washington y la otan